his quarterback  next [ __ ] win this is what i'm  talking about next buck is what we're  talking about  look at the brand calling for it rich  and he is from afghanistan  [Applause]  lebron james  wow  what a forum  [Applause]  at home  you  appreciate  what a game that was an unbelievable  game and finish  they're lucky to say we're in front of  me reg  give me the ball  i'm back  [Applause]  lebron james was two of 11 on threes  [Applause]  in this  [Applause]  and curry going not only for  [Applause]  [Music]  moments ago with the two defended by  levine and embiid well he built these  rims  he built these rails on you rich  it's only fitting right  oh thank you miss haddish  [Applause]  it's only finished  fitting that the king would come home  to his castle yes sir  and say game yes sir  night night  game-winning shot lebron james  and his team has won for a fifth  consecutive all-star game